how the Halloween go at the Olsen
household last night Greg well got a lot
of candy some trick or treating kids
were up until ten o'clock high sugar
rush and led for a early morning but we
had a good time kids loved it and it's
been fun fun watching them you know kind
of grow into their costumes here and
become little people how much pressure
is on the Olsen household to come up
with good candy though you know what my
wife handles it all and she usually
comes through we end up having way too
much candy we got everything from
Twizzlers Snickers we pretty much get
all the good stuff and since we're out
trick or treating we kind of just do the
whole come to our driveway with people
actually come up to the door because
we're outside with our crew going
everybody else's house so good chance to
meet the neighbors we just moved into a
new neighborhood so got to meet a lot of
people and told my wife is we got to
make sure we deliver we want to be the
new people and on the block that give
away little bite-size pieces you know
greg is joining us on behalf of fan
chest it's the perfect gift for sports
fans it's filled with exclusive products
not available in stores or online
delivered right to your door and why
don't you tell me about fan chest and
fan chest calm Greg yeah it's really
it's pretty incredible thing I mean what
Sanchez you can go to fan chest calm and
it's really the ultimate gift for for
sports for sports fans you can custom
customize your box to whatever
particular team if you have a favorite
player and it'll be just like we have a
lot of other concepts it'll be sent
right to your right to your door when
you open it there'll be some surprise
gifts there for your favorite team
different themes and portions of the
proceeds are going to our foundation for
this month for breast cancer awareness
so there's a charity aspect of doing
good work so it's been great working
with fan chests we're really excited
about the growth of what we're what
we're building and you know people just
can't get enough of their favorite teams
and we're trying out service them with
new merchandise and new products yeah
the website is fan chest comma talking
to Greg Olson the Carolina Panthers
tight end what's the mood with the
Panthers now after that we
against Arizona having it just gives us
a chance that you know just catch our
breath obviously the season didn't go
prior to the x didn't go as we all had
expected being one in five at the by was
obviously a disappointment and then you
know we knew coming out of the bye we
had ten games to go and you know we
weren't gonna we weren't going to ease
our way in you know coming off to buy
with a team like Arizona who we faced
not too long ago in the NFC Championship
is that talented as they get you know
had the second ranked defense in the
league we knew was going to be a
challenge for us so you know to get that
win under our belt here and you know
have nine more to go we just feel like
you know one at a time like everyone
says but that was definitely a good one
for us to get us back on track catch our
breath regroup and get ready to play
another one this weekend what was your
reaction when you realize what cam
newton was saying at the press
conference talking about how he's
officiated differently and he's going to
talk to the commissioner I think it's
been something that's been discussed
since the opening night out in Denver I
don't think this was was in you know
breaking news i think it's been a
storyline that's been discussed i think
it's been something that's been on
everybody's mind the differences is
really the first time cam has really
spoken out prior to this everyone kind
of spoke on his behalf he kind of took
the high road and didn't really you know
make it a point but I think he just
finally was fed up I think enough was
enough you know obviously took that big
low hit that wasn't called there in the
red zone in the third quarter and you
know I think the scary thing for him is
you know of course the penalty and all
that but you know he could have been
seriously hurt there so I think it all
kind of came to a came to a boil and he
just felt that it was finally his chance
in his time to to make a statement and
put his thoughts out there and he has
every right to do that do defenses hit
him differently I think what's funny
about the whole thing is people's
immediate reaction is well you know if
he wants to run as a running back then
he can't complain when he gets hit yeah
but the funny thing is when he runs as a
running back nobody hits him in the head
because they don't want to tackle him
heís so everyone dives and takes him out
that is when he's a runner when we're
running you know lead draws and we're
running you know set run plays for the
quarterback designed people aren't
hitting him on the head because they
don't want to take him on it's kind of
it's kind of funny because you
DBS and linebackers that are treating
him like a running back there hitting
them blow or tackle them like they
tackle Jonathan Stewart it's when he's a
pastor at 20 you know in in the pocket
it's when he's rolling flush and left
trying to extend extend to play that
that these guys come in and take all
these extra shots at him because he you
know he's not in a real defensive
position like he is when he's a ball
carrier so I think people need to be
able to say yes we when he is a runner
you can come and hit him as hard as you
can I don't think that's the problem i
think it's when he's a pastor he's no
different than any other person who's a
passer in this league regardless of his
size regardless of his rush attempts
when he's clearly a passer which is very
clear to determine he should have the
same protections and the same rules to
go by that every other player in the
league does regardless of his ability to
run he's Greg Olson to the Panthers also
joining us on behalf of fan chest you
can learn more at van chess.com it
seemed to get chippy in that game
against Arizona and I even read where
was there something going on after the
game where the Cardinals were talking
about you or coming after you yeah I
mean a couple of their guys I guess
we're having you know they didn't like
the way we finished the game you know we
were in a four-minute mode clearly there
after the interception we we knew we
needed to burn the rest of the clock out
that last drive and we were able to do
that and we're able to take three you
know three minutes or so off the clock
and hand the ball over to them with just
a couple seconds and I guess their guys
took exception to a couple you know of
our blocks in a couple of our you know
we finished a couple and we were you
know we were Brian we were trying to
fight and scratch and win a game and in
those four minutes situations it's it's
no-holds-barred in there we're trying to
finish a game out we're fighting for
your life and you know I guess a couple
of their guys took took exception to
that and weren't too thrilled that to
the game but the odd sometimes the
nature of the business emotions run high
obviously they're probably not you know
thrilled obviously the last couple times
they've come to us hasn't gone great for
them so that's just the nature of the
game yeah but did they come after you
Greg after the game I mean they had some
words there at midfield I mean mowing
down physical that we made it there was
no physical nature or anything there was
nothing like that it was mostly just
word so it was
I wasn't too big a deal you can't hit a
guy after the game right no no there was
nothing okay I just want to know I I
don't know if you watch the bear well
you were doing trick-or-treating last
night but you played with the Bears you
play with Jay Cutler what is it that we
miss what was missing here with with the
National perception of Jay Cutler as
opposed to playing with him are we wrong
in what we see with him and don't see my
biggest thing with my experience with
Jay was was very positive I mean I had
nothing but fond memories not only of
playing there you know professionally
but also our personal relationship was
always one that was very strong we had
some success you know of course you know
my last game they're playing with jay
and bears was the NFC championship games
and we had success we had a good rapport
on and off the field I think it really
just boils down to that you know Jay is
going to do things his way and I think
when you're on his team and you realize
how much he cares about winning and how
hard he plays and obviously how talented
he is you you know you see him for what
he hit and I think the outside
perspective that doesn't have the
ability to see him all week and see his
preparation and see how he interacts
with the guys um you know they don't
have that that ability to to make those
assessments and I think Jays at the
point where he understands everyone's
going to draw their own conclusions he's
never been one that's looking to change
people's minds he's going to be who he
is and and he's really in my experience
he's not overly concerned with with what
everybody else thinks it doesn't really
have much impact on on the way he
prepares himself in the way he goes
about his business so Mike Martz like
tight ends you'd probably still be in
Chicago when you yeah I think that's
fair i think i think the bears are even
on record just you know year to last
year it said said something along those
lines so i think that's pretty pretty
reasonable yeah i think they made a
little mistake why he didn't hey uh
thanks for joining us again good luck
with fan chest and of course next game
against the rams thank you Greg thanks
so much i appreciate it hey that's not
agree gelsen the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience